voici l'école primaire au ratio man à
l'heure de l'ouverture une notice
indique que le personnel féminin
respectera la grève mais elle ne dit pas
que l'école restera fermée la même école
vendredi matin à 8 heures les
enseignants sont presque tous des femmes
la station de métro bal des races
grouille de monde un jour normal elle
est reliée à une grande ligne d'autobus
c'est l'heure de l'arrivée au travail et
voilà la station balnéaire à ce matin on
voit partout que les femmes sont très
peu nombreuses de toute la matinée on
n'a pas eu d'enfant ils sont tous à la
maison
beaucoup de grandes compagnies ont
permis à leur personnel féminin de
respecter la grève un avis de la grande
banque banamex précise que comme 60% de
ses employés sont des femmes
de nombreuses succursales resteront
fermées la plupart des institutions
publiques les divers gouvernements ont
aussi laissé libre choix à leurs
employés le fédéral est aussi la ville
de mexico exception les policières
la ville ne leur a pas permis de faire
grève ça dérange cette policière parce
que ces enfants n'ont pas d'école elle
doit les faire garder ce salon de
coiffure et bien ouvert mais il est vide
les patrons ne savent pas si une des
quatre coiffes eux se présentera au
travail dans la journée ce mouvement
india sino se tracent un jour sans nous
a été déclenchée le mois dernier après
les meurtres horribles d'ingrid et de la
petite fatima sept ans en plus de
protester contre la violence on veut
montrer que les femmes sont
indispensables pour l'économie et la
bonne marche du pays au travail comme à
la maison
mais une grande partie l'économie
mexicaine est informel les vendeurs des
rues sont innombrables
les mexicains se nourrissent
régulièrement de cette façon ces femmes
n'ont pas une journée à perdre sont pas
salariés qui veut payer notre journée
nous devons travailler distincts cette
commerçante et contre la grève
le parrot
nom lamouri va peut-être les gars de
l'homme mais ça n'arrivera jamais le
chef du foyer c'est l'homme c'est la
bible qui dit et l'amusement arrivent
les indices et non un peu partout le
silence se brise devant ce grand collège
un mur de la dénonciation des étudiantes
accuse nommément des professeurs des
élèves masculins d'agressions à
caractère sexuel la plupart du temps
elles restent impunis dix sept
psychologues des criminalistes gilenya
compte à moscou a condamné il y a des
lois mais ce n'est pas suffisant sur le
terrain les accusations ne vont nulle
part il existe une très grande impunité
[Musique]
la première grève des femmes a eu lieu
en islande en 1975 et elle a
radicalement changé la société de l'île
le dias il non sans trace aura-t-il le
même effet sur la violence au mexique
web en question jean michel le mexique
part de loin est ce que toutes ces
manifestations contre les féminicides
commence à avoir des effets écoutez il
faudrait qu'il y a des effets c'est s
est pratiquement inévitable cette
manifestation hier était extraordinaire
on parle d'un demi million de personnes
dans la rue évidemment surtout des
femmes et cette grève générale
aujourd'hui a été encore plus suivi que
ce qu'on pensait on croyait qu'à peu
près la moitié des femmes la suivre
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus que ça la
capitale étaient pratiquement paralysés
ça n'ira pas si vite qu'on vous qu'on le
voudrait bien sûr hier par exemple jour
internationale de la femme
lors de cette grande manifestation et b
ya eu cinq femmes assassinées au mexique
dans des états où règnent le crime
organisé comme michoacan par exemple
guanajuato et où l'impunité est encore
plus grande qu'ailleurs alors vous voyez
ça sera pas du jour au lendemain il y
aura encore le drame épouvantable
ces tensions compte neuf à dix
assassinats de femmes par jour
ouais mais quand même il y à quelques
initiatives qui voit le jour à mexico
notamment ah oui et ça c'est intéressant
le sel qui dirige la ville de mexico
c'est une femme
cloud a chip cloud yashine chez une
barbe et cette semaine elle a lancé un
programme s'appelle sos mujeres sos
femmes il y aura un groupe de quatre
mille travailleurs sociaux qui vont
aller systématiquement dans tous les
foyers deux par deux trente par jour il
y aura deux millions sept cent mille
foyers qui seront visités on veut
détecter à l'avancé les possibilités de
violences familiales
on veut dresser une sorte de violence au
m donc ça c'est à suivre
elle est du même parti que le président
lopez obrador est ce que ce sera suivie
à l'échelle du pays ça ça serait
intéressant oui un premier pas quand
même merci beaucoup jean-michel derrière
au revoir